[Music]
Jacob Sartorius here I wanted to quickly
make this video to let everybody know
that Tuesday November 6 is Election Day
and everybody needs to get out there and
go vote if you're not old enough to vote
like me you can still get involved by
going to the phone banks volunteering
and there's tons of more stuff but my
generation us as generations II we need
to be the generation known for igniting
change and having our voices heard so go
get involved go tell your friends family
parents grandparents even your uncle
that Tuesday November 6 is voting day
thanks
[Music]
calling all use it is time to vote
if you are eligible to vote and have not
registered yet then what are you doing
you need to register I am gonna be able
to vote in this election and I'm so
excited to allow my voice to be heard
you know this is a pivotal one and it's
gonna be my first time voting and it's
gonna be great but I need all of you to
vote as well we need to create change
and do it collectively so let's do this
hey guys it's Brooklyn and Bailey and it
is super important for all of us
teenagers to vote and everyone in
general because our ancestors fought and
gave up their lives so that we can have
the right to vote and so we need to
exercise that right and honor them in
that and so if you aren't registered to
vote be sure to do that right now so
that we can all vote
hey I'm Joshua rush I want you to vote
to show your lawmakers that young people
aren't just to be told get off my lawn
too we're an important part of the
voting electorate and it's time for us
to make our voices heard
[Music]
this generation of American teenagers is
diverse and fearless and so powerful we
strive to better our country and we
fight for our natural rights and this is
why it is so important for us to turn
our words into action and vote to get a
brighter future for ourselves and the
ones that come after us because if we
don't do it no one's going to do it
before us remember that no matter how
young you are you have a voice too so
please use it
[Music]
us young voters account for half of the
voting population which makes us a huge
powerful political voice I just want to
tell you guys I hope you all vote this
year and we are the change and we can
definitely make a difference so if you
can vote this year definitely go out and
vote
[Music]